[موسيقى]
لدينا استراتيجيه خاصه لذلك وهي قائمه على
ان نقل المعرفه التكنولوجيه السريه هو امر
يشكل جزءا من سياده الدول بغض النظر عن
الدوله التي نمثلها وبالتالي اعمل على
حمايتها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
استراتيجيتنا هنا في الشرق الاوسط هي
البدء في بناء هذه المعرفه وبالطبع حسب
اسلوب ساب بتنفيذ اعمالها سواء العمليات
الاجرائيه او القوالب المعده مسبقا اي
طريقه انجازنا لاعمالنا بشكل عام
[موسيقى]
فنحن نرى اننا تعلمنا علما اننا ناتي من
دوله صغيره بميزانيه محدوده حيث ان السويد
دوله صغيره نسبيا بتعداد سكان عشره ملايين
تعلمنا ان نعمل بذكاء وكذلك بكفاءه عاليه
ناهيك عن مساله التعاون مع شركاء اخرين
سواء الشركات الحكوميه العامله في هذا
القطاع او المؤسسات الاكاديميه وهذا نراه
ايضا احد سبل النجاح لكن الاساس هو اقامه
الشركه هنا ومن ثم استقطاب الموارد
البشريه المناسبه والاصول اللازمه واخيرا
تطبيق طرق عملنا هنا
[موسيقى]